في بريطانيا كشف قصر بوكينغهام عن بعض
التفاصيل المتعلقه قبل تتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث في السادس من مايو المقبل من
المقرر ان يتوجه تشارلز وزوجته كاملا الى
كاتدرائيه التي تقام فيها المراسم في احدث
عربه ملكيه وهي عربه اليوبيل التي تم
تصميمها في استراليا لاحتفال بمرور 60
عاما على اعتلاء الملكه الراحله اليزابيث
عرش البلاد ودخلت الخدمه لاول مره عام
2014 وخلال العوده الى بوكينغهام سيستخدم
تشارلز وكمل اقدم عربه ملكيه تعود الى 260
عاما وسخدمت في كافه مراسم التنصيب ووفقا
للقصر سيكون تتويج تشارلز في احتفال يغلب
عليه العظمه وسط تقاليد تعود الى الف عام
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات